hey what's up my name's samuel lives in
this video i want to talk about
university
is university a waste of time is
university a scam
should you go to university or is it a
really good thing is it going to set you
up for life
it's going to give you a foundation so
you can progress in your career if you
choose to have a career
uh what do i think about university the
thing that made me want to do this video
was in my facebook group the property
investors with samuel leeds facebook
wrote
it's a big argument going on right now
there was a guy called nick
nick's part of samuel 365 community and
nick posted and nick basically said
you know he somewhere about university
that wasn't great
okay like don't don't spend tens of
thousands going to university
blah blah blah i don't know what it was
but all our stories everyone was
commenting getting really upset with
nick
and they're saying you know oh you know
that's terrible you i went to university
how dare you say that everyone's getting
all upset
and i wanted to give my opinion on this
because i think the answer i think it's
very straightforward this whole thing is
very straightforward
is university a waste of time is it good
is it bad would i recommend it what am i
going to say to my kids
i've got three kids now so i need to
know what am i going to say to my kids
and i think i think um here's my
thoughts
my thoughts are that university is
neither good or bad
it's neither a waste of time or a good
use of time
university is university and
it's a tool okay it's a tool
that can be used to get you where you
want to get to now
if you want to be a doctor that's your
life
that's your now if you haven't even got
a goal if you're like i don't know what
i want to do
then then you shouldn't even be watching
this video you should like you can't
even have an opinion
if if you haven't even got goals you're
just like i don't know i'll just go
be pissing in the wind then it's like
well
this debate is probably you shouldn't
even think about this the you did you be
before you do anything
you need to be thinking about what do i
want in life right that's the first
thing
what do you want in life what's your
goal what's the outcome that you want of
your life
if that's to be a doctor guess what
you're gonna need to go to university
to become a doctor so university is good
i'd say do it if you want to be a lawyer
you got to go to uni
you want to be uh you want to be um a
barrister or you want to be a
there's lots of jobs where you need to
be you need to go to uni
you need to get qualified now what
people are saying
when they say don't go to uni it's a
waste of time is if your goal
doesn't require going to university if
you want to be a property millionaire
if you want to run a successful business
and employ people guess what
you don't need to go to uni it is a
complete waste of time
it is i'm in real estate i'm in property
right i'm buying
my net worth is 16 million pounds i
started from scratch i've been in
property for 12 years
going to university for me would have
been a complete waste of time
because when i go to the bank to try and
get
a loan to buy a property when i'm
getting mortgages and stuff
they don't ask me what did you get at
school what were your exams
what accreditation certificate have you
got they don't ask me that what they ask
me is ask me for my
financial credentials what they ask me
is they ask me
what are you investing into let's look
at the property and see if the deal
stacks
so what i need is i need to work on my
financial credentials i need to work on
finding deals that stack i need to build
my experience i need to get my
relationships and network and power to
that is what you need to do if you want
to be a property millionaire so
i think it's very simple the answer is
very simple is university a waste of
time it depends
if you have a you need to set a goal
okay this is where i want to get to
and then you need to work out how you're
going to get there i have people saying
but samuel what about if i do real
estate at university
and look i haven't done real estate at
university but i've spoke to people that
have and they spend a lot of time
talking about things like you know the
technical
what's inside the windows of a property
and
you don't need to know that you know you
don't need to know that stuff
so i mean i went to college i went to
birmingham bible institute for three
years
and i studied theology now i didn't do
that for a certificate at the end of it
i didn't do that to help me get a job i
did that very simply because i wanted to
do it for my own enjoyment
alongside my property business fine
so to say it's bad or it's good or you
should do it or you shouldn't
it's quite an ignorant thing to say
because it really depends on the person
so
let's stop judging people for what they
choose to do with their life
you know we need doctors we need lawyers
we need
people to go to university what i think
is
is a little bit immature is when people
go to university
to study drama and get into 40 000
pounds worth of student debt
just because they don't know what to do
oh well i don't know what to do and it's
like come on
think think about what you want to do
plan your life and then go make it
happen
and don't judge anybody else and i mean
it's so funny because when i started in
property everyone was judging me like
what are you doing going to these
courses and trying to be a property
you're crazy what are you doing like i
was some renegade
but now now the pendulum's almost turned
now it's almost like um
that's cool now that's in you know if
you go to uni it's like oh where are you
where you going to uniform trying to get
a job there's nothing wrong with going
to uni getting a job
there's nothing wrong with that if you
want to do that there's nothing wrong
with having a job
i employ people the guy holding this
camera has got a job
with me right now yeah
did you go to university yeah i did but
not for this
you went to what did you study
accounting accounting yeah
i don't even know see when people come
to work for me
okay generally speaking i don't care if
they went to university or not
you know i mean we've got very very
people very very well paid people
in that company and some went to uni
some didn't what i want to know as an
employer is
what value can you bring to the table
right so new smart who's a good marketer
i mean i i've known people that he went
and studied accounting and now he's
working in marketing
that's another thing a lot of advice
that we hear from
the older generation are giving advice
that worked 50 years ago but doesn't
work today
new student accounting and then now he's
working in videography and marketing
a good job for life doesn't exist
anymore it doesn't exist so you could
study something at uni
and then change your mind on that topic
or it doesn't work out but then you just
got a degree in i don't know
i think you just need to think it
through really carefully and not just
anybody else that's my opinion
and i think as well something really
interesting people say but samuel is a
good fallback option
you know people typically get paid more
if they've been to uni it's like 10
20 more than people that didn't go to
uni it's like yeah because they've got
better jobs
mostly but ones if you don't want a job
if you want to be a business owner then
it doesn't really help
so uni is neither good nor bad depends
on what you want to do
figure out what the outcome is of your
life
and then plan the route to get there and
if universities needed to get there
go to university if it's not
don't go to university just because
everybody else does you've got to create
your own life
so that's my thoughts let me know what
you think do you agree with me
do you disagree with me is university
overrated it depends on the circles that
you're in some people massively
overestimate university yeah
it's overrated but some people maybe
underestimate
i'll tell my kids i'll say what do you
want what do you want to be and if i say
i want to be a doctor i'll say you sure
yeah i'm sure daddy all right what are
you going to do some work experience for
a doctor why don't you see
why don't you go and talk to some
doctors and see how much they're working
how much they're getting paid
are they happy and then if you really
want to be a doctor
after you've done all that then great go
to university and be a doctor
if you don't if you want to be a
property millionaire or you want to be a
business owner then great
then go down a slightly different path
but you do what you need to do don't
judge anybody else
what do you think comment below let me
know join the debate
join the debate on the property
investors with samuel lee's facebook
group head down i'll leave a link in the
description
and uh see you all soon hope to see the
property investors crash course
so you want to be in real estate you
want to be a millionaire in property
don't go to uni come on the crash course
it's free it's one pound on the house i
will leave a link in the description as
well
and let me know your thoughts on this
video comment your opinion i'll see you
real soon subscribe
thanks for watching peace out